in this video we'll talk about dopamine
which is a neurotransmitter dopamine is
associated with motivation reward
euphoria that means it's kind of like a
feel-good factor dopamine is a monoamine
and chemists call them catecholamine
so let's talk about the dopamine
biosynthesis dopamine is synthesized
from the amino acid tyrosine tyrosine
gets converted to l-dopa with the help
of the enzyme tyrosine hydroxylase
l-dopa gets further converted to
dopamine by a decarboxylation reaction
triggered by aromatic L amino acid
decarboxylase
once dopamine is synthesized dopamine
gets packaged into the synaptic vesicles
where it is released in the synaptic
lift now once released dopamine binds to
dopamine receptors dopamine receptors
are metabotropic receptors that means
they are G protein coupled receptors
there are two categories D1 like
receptors which involves D1 and D5
and D2 like receptors which involve D2
D3 and D4 so all the D1 type receptors
are GS coupled that means they activate
adenylate cyclase and generate cyclic
amp and the D2 receptors are actually GI
coupled receptors that means they
inhibit adenylate cyclists in different
circuitry we get different balance of
these kind of receptors and that
modulates the difference in the dopamine
response dopamine uptake is really
important because once released in the
cleft it doesn't stay in the synaptic
clip for long it is getting re-uptaken
by specific Transporters known as
dopamine Transporters and eventually
they get degraded and cleared out from
the synaptic cleft
now dopamine breakdown is a regulated
process dopamine gets converted to 3-4
dihydroxyphenyl acetic acid with the
help of monoamine oxidase or Mao
dopamine can also get converted to three
methoxy tyramine with the help of
cathical O methyl transferase and both
these products can eventually be
converted to homovanic acid and thereby
dopamine is degraded
so there are particular medications such
as MAO inhibitors or comt Inhibitors
which prevent the degradation of
dopamine allow the dopamine to persist
and these are antidepressants and many
other cases these medicines are used so
let's ask where can we find dopaminergic
neurons in our brain so if we look at
the brain we can find dopaminergic
Pathways in various places first of all
we should see the dopaminergic neuronal
cell bodies in the ventral tegmental
area and also in the substantia [ __ ] so
all the pathways are projecting towards
either cortex which is known as the
mesocortical pathway or the striatum
which is known as the Nitro striatal
pathway which protects projects from the
substantia [ __ ] to the stratum and also
the Mesolithic pathway the Mesolithic
pathway is red highlighted because this
is associated with motivation the
mesocortical pathway is associated with
cognition memory emotion learning Etc
whereas the nigrostatal pathway is
involved in sensory stimuli movement
motor control etcetera but mesolimic
pathway is specifically associated with
pleasure reward seeking behaviors
addiction emotion Etc
now let's talk about dopamine and
disease when we talk about dopamine the
first thing that comes in our mind is
Parkinson's Disease because in the
Parkinson's disease the key pathological
symptom is the death of dopaminergic
neuron in the substantia [ __ ] so if we
look at the normal individual we can see
the substantial [ __ ] look like this a
black band because of the presence of
neuro melanin and it is basically
meaning the black substances now if we
compare that with the Parkinson patient
we can see the substantial [ __ ] is
reduced in the appearance and there is a
massive cell death in substantia Niagara
so the motor coordination problem in
Parkinson's disease is associated with
the dopamine deficiency so when the
dopamine levels are low there could be
Tremors uncoordinated movement shuffling
of the gate overall dysregulated motor
behaviors
now there are specific medications which
prevent the dopamine reuptake so
dopamine reuptake
if it is inhibited then dopamine would
persist in the synaptic cleft for longer
or dopamine degradation Inhibitors such
as MAO inhibitors can also be useful to
treat these kind of Parkinson's disease
now dopamine can also be associated with
addiction for example Cookin addiction
is associated with dopamine cocaine
actually blocks the reuptake of dopamine
that means dopamine persists in the
synaptic cleft for a long time which
gives us a euphoria-like feeling and
that's why you get a craving for more
and more of cocaine right and that's how
you get addicted so in this video in
short we looked at dopamine biosynthesis
dopamine uptake dopamine breakdown where
we can find dopaminergic neurons in the
brain dopamine and disease dopamine and
addiction
you can get notes and flashcards in my
Facebook page follow us on Instagram all
the links are provided in the
description you can support the channel
via Bheem UPI app or PayPal or paytm so
if you
wish to support you can click on the
super thanks option which is in the
bottom right corner of the video and see
you in the next video in case you want
to get connected with us in social media
feel free to do so all the links are
provided in description